exit bonjour heureux de vous retrouver
ce matin sur rtl france alors edouard
philippe a donc lancé son nouveau parti
ce samedi au havre dans quel but alors
une dance with horizon donc l'horizon
vous savez c'est l'imaginaire qu'on n'a
pas jamais même si on marche pas dans le
but je pense de faire marcher les
marcheurs 50 plus c'est un peu l'idée en
disant il a besoin d'un socle plus large
et menées de macron pour lancer sa
campagne parce que là public en marche
c'est un parti qui n'a plus vraiment le
vent en poupe un même s'ils ont un siège
énorme dans le coeur de paris qui sont
en train de former de nouveaux militants
et d'essayer de relancer les tic est en
marche on l'a vu les élections
intermédiaires que ce soit les
municipales et régionales en marche n'a
pas séduit et donc avec horizon edouard
philippe essaye de faire un pôle de
droite avec des maires quelque chose
d'un peu plus sérieux des élus qui ont
une connaissance du terrain puisque ça a
été critiqué le fait que la public en
marche était imparti hors sol avec
beaucoup de députés mais très peu d'élus
locaux la edward fini tu cherche à faire
le lien est déjà très vite un des maires
monsieur falco à toulon a été mis en
examen pour abus de biens sociaux donc
ça va très vite horizon il ya déjà des
gens qui ont des conflits d'intérêts qui
sont dans le cadre de ce parti donc le
but je pense c'est d'abord d'aider
emmanuel macron à ces élections est de
penser aussi à lui edouard philippe pour
2027 et est-ce que edouard philippe peut
être un des piliers de la maison commune
souhaitée par emmanuel macron pour
pousser sa candidature en 2022 c'est ce
qu'il veut clairement lui l'a expliqué
l'élargissement
l'idée c'est de poser un des pilier
supplémentaire à cette maison commune
qui est la volonté des malades macron
d'avoir une plate forme programmatique
large pour le pousser à nouveau en 2022
en étant candidat puisque la reine comme
je disais un parti qui est en train de
s'auto dissoudre sans eau sans même le
vouloir le problème d'edouard philippe
c'est qu'il arrive un peu tard pour la
bataille equidia face à lui françois
bayrou qui lui compte est le pilier
comme il l'a été en 2017 et le rester
avec davantage de députés pour le modèle
etc or sur ce point là on voit qu'il ya
une guerre des droites qui se fait au
sein de la république en marche au sein
de cette maison commune pardon avec les
centristes et puis edouard philippe qui
représente un peu les nouveaux juppéiste
donc des gens beaucoup plus de droite on
a vu sa plate forme programmatique c'est
plus d'autorité plus d'austérité aussi
rien de nouveau sous le soleil
finalement avec ce nouveau parti de
d'edouard philippe si ce n'est de
vouloir prendre la place de de françois
bayrou dans la construction de cette
nouvelle maison commune évidemment à ce
que la droite elle avait besoin d'un
parti de plus
la droite et la patente parti que ça
mais là beaucoup de candidats c'est vrai
et de la voir à nouveau arriver de voir
philippe avec ses pensées à peine
dissimulé un pour 2027 clairement ça
pose question il est là je pense edouard
philippe dans un calcul celui de dire
les républicains vont avoir fort à faire
avec la candidature d'eric zemmour si
les candidats mais aussi avec la suite à
donner compte tenu des résultats qui
seront les leurs lors de la
présidentielle on voit bien que chez les
républicains on commence à réfléchir a
explosé ce parti est issu de l'ump la
majorité présidentielle pour refaire les
deux droits atteint qu'on connaissait
une droite beaucoup plus à droite qui
serait représenté peut-être par ces mots
et d'autre et puis une droite centriste
que edouard philippe souhaiterait
incarné plus largement françois bayrou
donc oui la droite n'a pas forcément
besoin d'un nouveau parti et n'a pas non
plus besoin d'un nouveau candidat mais
jusqu'à preuve du contraire et de voir
philippe reste loyale et on a vu un son
parti est fait pour brouiller les pistes
de même police de caractère même slogan
quasiment à vous voir loin pour aller
plus loin enfin bon on a l'impression
d'un b d e d'école de commerce donc ça
ressemble vraiment en marche et puis
derrière on na christophe castaner
ancien ministre des malades mâcon qui
est là pour dire où surtout n'hésitez
pas à les voir horizon puisque en plus
on perd par la double appartenance donc
il n'est pas vraiment un candidat de
droite aujourd'hui edouard philippe il
est surtout un support des macros merci
beaucoup alexis l édito politique d'eric
poulain c'est tous les lundis matin dans
la matinale de france